Let me close this section with my favorite story on bug reproduction.
In 2002, I went to a conference to give a laptop demonstration of a complex software system.
Before I left, we had taken every precaution
so that the software would run perfectly.
But then came the evening before the demonstration.
I would be sitting in my hotel room and try out,
for the last time, so everything would be working fine.
Nothing worked. The software would run into timeout errors anytime, everywhere.
I phoned my department at home.
They had the same software, on the same machine, and everything worked.
I debugged this for 3 hours in a row.
My battery had even run out of power, so I had to recharge it.
That's when I decided to restart from scratch.
To my amazement, the demo now ran just fine.
And so I wondered, why did the program work after restarting from scratch?
Was this because of some caching problem?
Did this have something to do with the battery?
Was this because I reinstalled everything?
Or because of cosmic radiation?
Hint: I gave you an indication right within the story.
Over to you.